ferdinand bombón marcos el hijo del
fallecido dictador ferdinand marcos
declaró ganador de las elecciones
presidenciales celebradas el lunes 9 de
mayo esto cuando todavía se esperan los
resultados oficiales que tardarán varias
semanas según el conteo provisional
marcos obtuvo más de 31 millones de
votos lo que representa más de el 56 por
ciento de los apoyos el doble de su más
inmediata rival
lenis robredo cientos de filipinos han
salido a las calles a protestar por esta
victoria y temen volver a lo que llaman
los horrores de la dictadura
marcos padres de provocó más de 3000
muertos ejecutados extrajudicialmente
más de 35 mil torturados y también
desfalco diez mil millones de dólares a
las arcas públicas durante su régimen
autoritario entre 1965 y 1986 para
analizar entonces lo que ocurre en
filipinas este fenómeno y lo que ha
pasado con esta victoria inminente
defenderán marcos juniors quiero saludar
a marta
falguera y es analista política
asia-pacífico para la orden mundial y
también international institute for
global strategic análisis gracias a
marta por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de frank 104 pregunto qué
significa entonces la victoria ferdinand
marcos junior en filipinas
muchas gracias raúl por tenerme como
invitada hoy aquí y bien en la victoria
de marcos lo que supone sobre todo
un regreso
al régimen de su padre no exactamente
igual es decir no sé no es lo mismo no
será otra dictadura pero sí que vuelve a
es un tema en el cual la sociedad
filipina aún sigue muy polarizada como
bien ha dicho usted
durante durante la dictadura de
ferdinand marcos hubo millones de
muertes hubo abusos a los derechos
humanos y además la familia marcos
desfalco una can 10 mil millones de
dólares a las arcas públicas es decir la
sociedad filipina aún se acuerda de eso
el problema está sobre todo en la en la
campaña de blanqueamiento que se ha
hecho y que se ha hecho no sólo durante
la campaña electoral estos últimos meses
sino en los últimos años e incluso te
llegaría a decir en las últimas décadas
por parte de ferdinand marcos hijo
le pregunto marta como asuma en esta
victoria a los países integrantes de la
asean
bien a los países de asean como siempre
o sea su máxima es la neutralidad sobre
todo con respecto a lo que pase con con
los países vecinos de la zona y sobre
todo con los otros componentes de la
asociación por lo cual
podrán tener una opinión u otra distinta
sobre sobre el vencedor pero lo van a
aceptar lo que sí es que por ejemplo en
con el vecino regional la estancia
regional que es china así que va a tener
un seguimiento de ese acercamiento es
decir con rodrigo de tercero antecesor
ya hubo ese acercamiento con china
por lo cual alejamiento de eeuu y ser
que con marcos juniors pase lo mismo
aunque quizá no del no de manera tan
exigente o de manera tan contundente
como como tote claro y cuál será
entonces marta la oposición política a
marcos o juniors quien se perfila como
el principal opositor a este nuevo
gobierno filipino a su principal rival
en y robredo ex abogada de derechos
humanos y hasta bueno estos últimos seis
años vicepresidenta junto en el gobierno
de rodrigo daughter te leen y robredo se
ha presentado en sobre todo haciendo
mella de lo que supone de lo que
supondría un regreso
de un familiar de marcos al poder y
sobre todo ha fomentado
las toda la guerra contra contra las
drogas que hizo duterte y lo que por
ejemplo pues un gobierno de marco
supondría esa continuación de ese tipo
de abusos por lo cual leen y robredo no
sólo en temas de política nacional
también en política internacional se
opone a marcos porque era la principal
garante de un acercamiento más a eeuu y
no tanto con china como recibe bombón el
país cuáles serían sus principales retos
bien a los principales retos de
filipinas son sobre todo a nivel
económico no solo los últimos dos años
pues la economía ya se ha resentido con
la pandemia sino que ya llevaban y
perdón bastantes años de pues recesión
económica sobre todo pues por ejemplo
eso fue una de las razones por las que
llevó a duterte a acercarse a china para
poder obtener financiación de de pekín
entonces pongan en el tema económico se
encuentra con problemas económicos
heredados de tu tercer y por eso se
espera que siga el mismo patrón que
duterte sobre todo para poder conseguir
financiación de manera más
de manera más fácil y obviando los
problemas que sea el legado que ha
tenido su familia en el país claro marta
y hablando del legado que país deja
también rodrigo ter si quiera pasar con
la dura política antidrogas de filipinas
va a continuar digamos
bien eso se espera de hecho se espera
que el gobierno de marco sea muy
continuista con el de meterte en muchos
aspectos no sólo por el acercamiento que
han tenido por él en estos últimos meses
sino porque sara duterte la hija de
rodrigo duterte va a ser su
vicepresidenta y también por el hecho de
que pongo marcos ya ha anunciado que va
a intentar durante su mandato bloquear
cualquier tipo de proceso que se le haga
contra duterte